Military Forces: We are not just the ones
that sit in the back anymore, we are actually
leading troops and leading a team, and hopefully
winning a battle out there.
13News Now: As we look at the people we need
to attract to serve in our military, if we
don t expand the numbers of women, we are
not going to have the people we need to do
the jobs.
SIERRA: For almost 80 years, women have served
this country in uniform, and today, over 200,000
serve in active duty forces. They are critical
to the military s success, and our national
security depends on their contributions, sacrifices,
and achievements. But as they protect us,
they are facing a threat that no soldier should
ever have to face.It is estimated that 1 in
4 servicewomen will experience a sexual assault
during their career in the military. And the
military s separate justice system, overseen
by commanders, has been criticized for its
low rate of conviction. The cost for each
survivor is incalculable. At the same time,
the trend is undermining our military s readiness,
and harming recruitment and retention. Last
week, the Pentagon announced that it will
implement an eight-year plan to curb these
crimes and to begin moving cases outside the
oversight of commanders. But will it be enough?
I m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It Matters.
Today, the important role of women in the
military, and the system that has failed them.
SIERRA: So what are some of the key facts
that you think people should know when it
comes to sexual assault and the military?
CHRISTENSEN: Well that it is at a crisis number
and it's not getting any better.
SIERRA: This is Don Christensen, a retired
Air Force colonel with 23 years of experience
as a military lawyer, also known as a judge
advocate, or a JAG. Currently, he is the President
of Protect Our Defenders, a human rights non-profit
seeking justice for survivors of military
sexual assault and sexual harassment.
CHRISTENSEN: So the military is required by
Congress to do a survey with active duty force
every two years. To get an estimate of the
prevalence rate of sexual assault and rape
among the active duty men and women who serve.
And that has been going on since 2006. It
averages well over 20,000 sex assaults a year.
That's just the active duty force, doesn't
count the reserve and guard or civilians that
are sexually assaulted by active duty members.
Over six percent of the women are sexually
assaulted or raped in a year, and we see very
little accountability.
MYERS: Some people in the Military will say,
" You know, one in four women, in uniform
is sexually assaulted." And that is pretty
on par with the rest of the United States,
the incidents of women being sexually assaulted.
But the big difference is that one in four
American women are not sexually assaulted
at work by their co-workers. And that's the
big rub in the Military, is that these are
your peers. And why is this so prevalent?
SIERRA: This is Meghann Myers, Pentagon Bureau
Chief for Military Times, which provides news
about service members at home and deployed
around the world.
MYERS: You know, if one in, one in four female
reporters were sexually assaulted by the reporters
in the newsroom, right? Or if one in four
female nurses were sexually assaulted by doctors
in the hospital, that would be outrageous.
You know, we would never accept that in those,
you know, small small communities, that prevalence.
These are, again, supposed to be the people
that you would die for. And yet, you are,
you know, victimizing them.
SIERRA: According to the Defense Department
s Annual Report on Sexual Assault in the Military,
a DoD survey indicated that in the fiscal
year of 2018, 20,500 service members were
sexually assaulted or raped, including 13,000
women and 7,500 men. Of these only 203 incidents
resulted in conviction. That s less than one
percent. These are wounds that cut deep. A
2020 DOD report found that sexual assault
in the military is more likely to cause post-traumatic
stress disorder than combat. The statistics
clearly show that both men and women are suffering
sexual assault in the Military, but its a
huge topic, so in this episode we are going
to be primarily focusing on women.
SIERRA: So, obviously, the deepest consequence
of this issue exists in the damaged lives
of survivors, the pain that they have had
to endure, but what are the other consequences?
How does this problem hurt the military?
CHRISTENSEN: Well, let's start with this,
in an all-volunteer force, the American Military
cannot meet its requirements if women don't
serve. They make up 15 to 16 percent of the
military. If you take that 15 to 16 percent
out, we do not have enough qualified men who
are willing to serve to fill that role. Second
thing is just the cost. You know, these women
range from brand new trainees in basic training
to colonels and even generals and admirals
that are sexually assaulted. They choose overwhelmingly
to leave. That is a huge cost that we have
in that. It costs so much to train a pilot
or train an infantry officer or a medical
personnel, and to have them choose to leave
or be forced out because of this is a massive
talent pool drain for the services.
SIERRA: More than 1 in 4 survivors of sexual
assault, harassment, or discrimination have
taken steps to leave the military. The talent
drain creates serious consequences for military
capabilities, including for tasks that only
women can perform.
MYERS: So the best example of women in a mission,
in combat, doing something that men could
not do, does involve this most recent operation
in Afghanistan. Basically, the idea was, when
counterinsurgency, which is having troops
go into villages, into neighborhoods, win
hearts and minds, you know, that was the way,
that was how, what we called it. In order
to integrate with those people and to learn
about what they needed in the village, getting
women on board, being able to talk to women
about what they needed was crucial. And in
these very conservative Muslim communities,
women are not allowed to talk to men who are
not in their families. So they could not talk
to the male soldiers, who were coming to the
village to speak to the village elders. And
so special operations decided, "Okay, how
about we train, you know, some teams of women
who can go in and do that engagement?" And
that is what they've been doing all along.
A woman, Ashley White was her name, actually
died in combat in Afghanistan in one of these
teams when she was serving with Army Special
Forces. So while women who serve just want
to be seen as a service member like any other
service member, there are examples like that
where being a woman made somebody more useful
in a situation, than the men who they were
serving with.
SIERRA: So how does sexual assault impact
units on the ground?
MYERS: So you could ask anybody in the military,
you know, "What are the most important things
for combat effectiveness?" And unit cohesion
is chief among them. Which means everybody
is watching out for each other, they're on
the same page, they're willing to, you know,
defend each other under any circumstance.
And along those lines, there are also senior
leaders in the military who will referred
to sexual assault as fratricide, which is
basically killing your brother or sister,
attacking your brother or sister. And that
is, you know, ideally the way that senior
leaders want the issue to be looked at, because
when women in a unit do not feel safe, you
have destroyed the credibility, and the combat
effectiveness of that unit because you are
supposed to be watching out for each other,
and obviously, if you're assaulting each other,
it's not watching for each other.
SIERRA: To truly understand what s going on
here, it s important to understand the long
historical struggle for equality in the military,
and the way women s service roles have changed
over time.
MYERS: When women were first formally able
to serve in uniform dates back to World War
II, there were a couple of voluntary organizations
within the Army and the Navy, and those were
largely medical, healthcare, and otherwise,
you know, secretarial administrative roles.
Women started to be more involved in direct
action, you know, if you will, more into the
eighties and the nineties women were when
women were first allowed to serve on ships,
when women were allowed to pilot aircraft.
And then things were very status quo for a
while. In the early nineties, there was a
ban on women in direct combat roles. So that
was, you know, no infantry, no artillery,
no tanks, things like that. The feelings about
that really started to change because of the
global war on terror, because when we were
in Iraq and Afghanistan, it really didn't
matter if you were, you know, a female mechanic,
a female military police officer, you know,
a female supply sergeant, women were getting
shot at and getting blown up just as often,
you know, as men were, so women were in combat
despite not being allowed to really serve
in roles that were traditionally seen that
way. In 2016, Ash Carter, who was the Secretary
of Defense then, he decided, I'd like to get
rid of the combat exemption for women, period,
you know, we want women to be able to serve
in all roles unless the services can come
up with a good reason why not, and the services
elected not to make any excuses. And so all
of those roles did end up opening around 2017,
2018 is when you started seeing more and more
women assigned, particularly in Army and Marine
Corps infantry, which were kind of the last
bastions of male-only environments in the
military. And then more and more into special
operations roles as well. You know, there
are now women who serve in army special forces.
There are women in air force special operations,
and that gap is closing more than ever.
SIERRA: Today, women in the military are just
as essential as their male counterparts. But
they have only had equal opportunities for
a handful of years. As a result, many vestiges
of the military s traditionally all-male culture
remain.
MYERS: I think a lot of it has to do with
the way that women were integrated into the
military, which was incredibly traumatic and
problematic for a long time. They were degraded,
made to feel other, less than the entire time.
And that dehumanization, and that degradation
of women and their contributions really made
it a lot easier for their peers to harass
and assault them. And that sort of, othering
of women in the military still continues,
up and to the point where the Marine Corps
is just now integrating boot camp. The Marine
Corps has never let men and women train together
from the very first days in the service. And
that created a culture where there were Marines,
and then there were female Marines. And a
lot of that came from the fact that, you know,
"She doesn't do the same training as I did,
she's less than me. We have different fitness
standards. And that leads up to this dehumanization
that then makes people feel empowered to victimize
women that they serve with. So that's the
other part that s gonna take a much longer
time for them to tackle, versus you know,
changing the way that they prosecute these
things.
SIERRA: That said, the way these crimes are
prosecuted is an important part of the picture.
Crimes committed in the military are tried
in a completely separate justice system. This
system is overseen by commanders, rather than
civilian judges, and it operates according
to very different rules.
SIERRA:
So, other than what I ve learned in movies
like A Few Good Men, I don t know much about
the military justice system. Do you think
you walk me through how a sexual assault case
might be handled?
MYERS: So the first step following an assault
is a report, and you can report that to a
commander, to anyone in leadership, really.
And the idea is that it will get routed to
a criminal investigation unit. If you decide
that you would like it to be prosecuted. There
are two kinds of reports in the military:
restricted reports, which are basically for
data collection purposes, but don't result
in an investigation, and then unrestricted
ones that turn into an investigation. And
so you will see one of the services that are
local investigation units will come by do
a criminal investigation, that's you, you
know, you might be familiar with in the civilian
world, but the big difference in the military
is rather than that case being referred to
a prosecutor in a district attorney's office,
the commander of that unit gets to decide
whether charges are pressed. And then the
commander of that unit gets to decide whether
it goes to trial. So it is not at this point,
an independently adjudicated system, a judge,
and a jury do preside over the trial. But
again, the commander has the authority to
overturn the verdict or the sentencing in
that trial, if he or she feels that it was
not warranted.
SIERRA: That judge and jury, by the way, are
also military personnel.
MYERS: So that's everything from mishandling
weapons, from, you know, vehicle accidents,
DUIs, anything that happens, the commanders
administer justice in the military, as it
is now.
SIERRA: What are the obstacles a survivor
may face when thinking about coming forward?
CHRISTENSEN: Unlike the civilian system, where
if someone is sexually assaulted and they
choose to report, they're gonna go to law
enforcement. In the military, it's controlled
by the commander, the person who's the boss
of the suspect and often the boss of the victim.
They're gonna have a divided loyalty in that
case -
SIERRA: Right.
CHRISTENSEN: Which one do they choose? And
everything is revolved there. The investigation
occurs there, the prosecution, if it happens,
it occurs there. A victim's commander reviews
all the evidence. That victim's private life
is being ripped open. If there has been a
rape kit, the commander gets to see the results
of that. If there were photographs taken of
the rape kit, commander gets to see that.
If intimate images were taken, which often
happens, the commander gets to see that. That's
going to disincentivize a lot of people, knowing
that day in and day out, this guy that you
work for has been able to look at the most
horrible part of your life, and you're gonna
be thinking about that.
SIERRA: Right. I mean, you're reliving something
that's just so horrible over again, but then
also very publicly with, essentially, your
colleagues.
CHRISTENSEN: Yeah.
CHRISTENSEN: So the DOD also has to look at
retaliation thanks to Congress, and we know
from those same surveys that of the women
and men who come forward, about 64 percent
of them say they were retaliated against after
they -
SIERRA: Wow.
CHRISTENSEN: Came forward. Yeah, it's huge
numbers. The DODIG released a report in 2016
showing that one out of three women who reported
the sexual assault, were forced out of the
military within a year of reporting. Over
20 percent of them had a less than fully honorable
discharge. Retaliation looks like career consequences,
where you're not allowed to progress or you
don't get promoted. But retaliation is also
social retaliation and that can be incredibly
painful, because in the military environment,
your entire life revolves around that installation.
You eat there, you sleep there, you work there,
you shop there, you go to the movies there.
Everything is right there.
SIERRA: When we learn about the justice system
in civics class, a lot of time is spent focusing
on impartiality. That s a core tenant of how
justice is supposed to be carried out in the
U.S. But critics of the military system point
out that commanders often face a conflict
of interest when deciding cases.
MYERS: So, the commander is accountable for
the good order and discipline of the unit,
that also means that a commander can face
their own repercussions for not having control
over the good order and discipline of a unit.
And so, there's also a very high temptation
to under report, push things aside, couch
incidents, so that the commander doesn't look
bad. And that becomes a real conflict of interest,
obviously, when you have a rape in your formation,
and you have to decide whether there's gonna
be a trial or not because your name is gonna
be on that.
SIERRA: Do victims have the option of just
opting out of all of this, and going to the
civilian police?
MYERS: It depends. If it happens on a military
base, no. On a military base, the military
is responsible for justice. If it's something
that happens, you know, at an off base residence,
or an off base business, something like that
especially if it's service member on service
member, generally the law enforcement in military
communities will defer to commanders on the
base, for adjudicating something like that.
SIERRA: The military justice system comes
from a very old tradition, one that was aimed
at maintaining order within the ranks and
the structure of command. Advocates of this
system say that taking cases out of the chain
of command would undermine the authority of
commanders and therefore compromise discipline
and battle effectiveness. But there are some
examples from other countries that seem to
contradict that prediction.
SIERRA: Is this unique to the United States?
I mean, do other major countries have similar
legal rules for their military?
CHRISTENSEN: Most of our allies have moved
to a case where the military commander does
not make prosecution decisions, the default
is to go to the civilian prosecutors.
SIERRA: Australia, Germany, Canada, Great
Britain and Israel prosecute major crimes
outside the chain of command by professional
military prosecutors. And by most reasonable
measures, their militaries have remained effective.
Israel has come down particularly hard on
this issue, with IDF Chief of Staff, Aviv
Kohavi, saying Any attack on sexual grounds,
in speech or in deed, is an attack on human
dignity and constitutes a severe breach. As
we look for answers at home or abroad, and
comb through so many complexities, we risk
forgetting the living, breathing human beings
who have suffered as a result of this problem.
So we decided to speak to a survivor to hear
her story. She served with the National Guard,
which essentially follows the same justice
protocols as other active duty branches.
SEXTON: My name is Heather Sexton and I'm
currently a biologist at a pharmaceutical
testing company, but I used to be a Captain
in the Missouri Army National Guard.
SIERRA: Can tell us a little bit about your
assault.
SEXTON: Yeah. We were going to a huge event
in Utah, and I was part of the Advon team,
which basically means there's a team that
gets sent ahead of time to set everything
up so that when the exercise starts, it's
all ready to go and everyone else just has
to show up and start training. So it was a
small group of us, probably about eight people.
And I was the highest-ranking, so I was in
charge of everyone. And I was also the only
female there. There was this really long,
dark sidewalk leading down to the female barracks,
and just because there's supposed to be, like,
30 different states there, and it was just
this huge conglomeration of people, I wasn't
really comfortable walking back to the barracks
after we were done setting up late at night.
So I started having some of the members of
my team walk me back to my barracks, which
is honestly a little embarrassing when you're
the highest-ranking one there, but I felt
like it was really necessary at that point.
SIERRA: Heather told us that on one of these
evenings at the end of the walk she was sexually
assaulted by a team member.
SEXTON: The next morning I went and reported
everything to the Chaplain and the victim
advocate there, but that was in Utah, so it
doesn't really correlate to our state since
I was in the National Guard. So basically
they got me out of there, but I kind of had
to redo everything. All of the reporting once
I got back to Missouri.
SIERRA: What was the atmosphere like when
you went to report the assault that second
time?
SEXTON: It was honestly awful. Immediately
everybody knew. But the worst part was that
they had immediately transferred him to a
new unit and brought him home from Utah, and
the new unit they transferred him to was the
unit I had to go to report it. So I was standing
there two days after, and he walked in the
office.
SIERRA: Oh my gosh. What was the process for
handling your case? You know, were you optimistic
about them doing the right thing as it went
along?
SEXTON: No, not really. I had heard a lot
of horror stories. That's why I wasn't sure
initially if I wanted to report and go through
it or not, but then in the end I know I would
have, because that would have haunted me forever.
Even now knowing the outcome, I don't regret
reporting it.
SIERRA: So, how did the assault change your
experience at work? Because, you know, you
waited for the system to do its work. How
long did you wait, and what was it, you know,
like for you continuing to report and continuing
to work through that?
SEXTON: It was almost two years.
SIERRA: Wow.
SEXTON: And it was terrible. That was a small
unit, it was embarrassing. He was friends
with everybody. It was tough going and showing
up knowing that everyone knew and knowing
everyone didn't have my back.
SIERRA: Yeah. So, you know, what was the ultimate
outcome?
SEXTON: They validated my whole story, they
said that everything happened, but ultimately
my claim was unsubstantiated. I honestly was
so confused. I thought I had mentally prepared
myself for everything, I thought I already
knew how it works, but I never thought they
would tell me it happened, but it's okay that
it happened. So they just treated it like
a regular business meeting at drills, said,
"Can you come in the office really quick?"
And just read it off to me, like it was, I
don't know, I couldn't believe it. It had
been destroying my life for two years and
they just acted like it was a regular meeting.
And then on top of that, to really rub salt
in the wound, they gave me a letter from the
Brigadier General, the second-highest-ranking
officer in the state of Missouri, reprimanding
me, because I should have been more professional
that night.
SIERRA: So how long did you stay after that?
SEXTON: I got out as soon as I could, but
that wasn't very quickly. So I got the verdict
in January, I believe, and I was out by April.
SIERRA: I am just so incredibly sorry.
SEXTON: Thank you, I really appreciate you
guys shining light on it too. It's obviously
really important to me.
SIERRA: We reached out to the Missouri Army
National Guard and they replied that they
were prohibited from commenting on personnel
matters or investigations. Heather s story
is just one of many thousands. And, according
to the statistics, in recent years less than
1% of survivors have seen their case carried
through to conviction.
SIERRA: So what sort of sentencing do we see
in the Military system? You know, what are
the punishments? How often are they handed
out?
MYERS: It can be all over the place. You know,
anywhere from, a discharge, something other
than an honorable discharge. And you know,
docking pay, or, reducing someone in rank.
You know, there are people who are in prison
for rape in the Military. It's very rare that
that happens, only because, much like in the
civilian world, out of thousands of reports
that they get every year, a small handful
of those will go to trial and an even smaller
handful will result in a conviction, and a
sentence.
SIERRA: So what has the military done to address
this over the years?
CHRISTENSEN: One of the things they have done
is, basically try to train their way out of
this crisis. That hasn't been effective. The
training, I think, falls on, deaf ears. It
has resulted, I think, a lot of backlash.
There's, like, a term, being SHARPed. SHARP
stands for Sexual Harassment Assault Response
Program. That's an Army program. And so they'll
use that as a derogatory term to a soldier's
complaint. "Oh, she's trying to SHARP somebody.
Like, that's made up.
MYERS: The feeling here among senior leadership
is basically that the awareness and the infrastructure
that the services have built around trying
to, first trying to respond to it, but also
prevent it, that has been going on for nearly
a decade now. And there have been no measurable
drops in the incidents of sexual assaults
and no measurable increases in the prosecutions
or convictions of sexual assaults. And so
the feeling is, we tried all these other things,
a lot of very smart, experienced people think
that changing the way we prosecute them may
make a difference. And so they are willing
to try that to see if the numbers bear out.
SIERRA: For decades, efforts focused on prevention,
victim support, and bystander intervention.
The educational content was disseminated through
videos, posters, and classes. But experts
say this strategy missed the mark. And as
time went on, repeated attempts to fix this
problem failed. But things may be reaching
a turning point. Last week, the Department
of Defense announced a plan that aims to comprehensively
address this issue. Chief among its proposals
is a change that would move prosecutorial
decisions outside the chain of command in
cases of sexual assault. The news broke after
our guest interviews, but we reached back
out to them for comment. Both agreed that
the plan contains many good ideas. However,
they said that its 8 year implementation timeline
could be reversed by a new Administration
or a new Secretary of Defense. And despite
this major push, the DoD still cannot remove
authority from the chain of command without
congress. The Department of Defense is not
the only potential source of reform. Before
the announcement, there had already been two
proposals in Congress to address the problem.
In the Senate there is the Military Justice
Improvement and Increasing Prevention Act.
Helmed by Kirsten Gillibrand, it has garnered
bipartisan support and is expected to pass.
Kristien GILLIBRAND, PBS News: There s few
bills in Congress that have the support of
Bernie Sanders and Ted Cruz, both Chuck Schumer
and Mitch McConnell, but this bill does.
SIERRA: And in the House, there is a similar
bill, the Vanessa Guillen Military Justice
Improvement and Increasing Prevention Act.
There are still some questions about how the
Congressional legislation and the DoD s plan
will interact. But, if passed, they would
be some of the most significant military reforms
of our time.
MYERS: The Pentagon announced earlier this
year that they will start taking steps toward
removing sexual assaults and what they consider
related crimes, so like I said earlier, sexual
harassment, domestic violence, child abuse,
out of the chain of command. But kind of in
a, in a parallel lane, you have, legislation
from New York Senator, Kirsten Gillibrand,
that has a lot of support in the Senate, and
likewise, a decent amount of support in the
House of Representatives that would take all
major crimes out of the chain of command,
away from a commander's authority. It's a
little fuzzy as to where the definition is,
but that could be all felonies. So you know,
that could be assaults, and DUIs, and things
that are crimes, but are not inherently related
to military service. It is possible that those
things will all be handled independently,
still within the Military, but not at a commander's
discretion. So a commander's discretion would
go more toward, you know, accidents on a shooting
range or, you know, vehicle accidents, mishandling,
and that sort of thing.
SIERRA: Where does the legislation currently
stand?
MYERS: It was part of the, the most recent
National Defense Authorization Act, which
is the law that Congress passes every year
that basically tells the Military how it's
going to spend its money. But that is all
kind of in a holding pattern right now because
it's such an immense bill. And so, the House
and the Senate, like they always do, have
gone back and forth about which version they're
most interested in. So it will be a little
while longer, until we know whether that ends
up in that law. And also, you know, there's,
there's negotiations going on about whether
Congress even needs to get involved now because
the Pentagon said, "Okay we're gonna do sexual
assaults, you know. We're gonna fix this,
this was the most important thing." And so
maybe they will back off on, on taking all
other felonies out of the chain.
SIERRA: So what's your take on these different
proposals?
CHRISTENSEN: Well, I firmly believe that Senator
Gillibrand and Representative Speier have
the right view on this, that we should be
moving all felonies over. Senator Gillibrand,
Senator Ernst, have over 60 cosponsors in
the Senate, they have the majority of the
Senate Armed Services Committee, her legislation
was put into the markup of the National Defense
Authorization Act. So it looks like it's going
to come out of the Senate version. So I think
as long as they're part of the NDAA, and they're
virtually identical, which they are, it's
a really good chance they'll pass.
SIERRA: The future of the legislation seems
bright. And that s a good thing, because if
a solution is not found, the problem could
hinder recruitment efforts for years to come.
SIERRA: So what's lost, if the U.S. military
can't retain and promote women?
MYERS: The Military will become, as some people
already argue it is, out of touch with American
people, with American civilization, with what
goes on in the outside world, and that goal
that they have to reflect the people that
they serve will be lost. And, there are people
who argue that, back in the '80s and '90s,
when women were all in support roles and were
pretty marginalized, that you know, we were
still the greatest fighting force. But the
issue becomes, you know, we're living in this
modern world, this modern world includes women
in, you know, leadership roles, and it only
stands to reason that you would see that in
the military as well. And the other thing
is that the services are having harder and
harder time attracting high quality recruits
to man these organizations. And so, if you
alienate women from that population you are
alienating roughly 50% of the American people.
And kind of hamstringing your chances of having
a fully manned force.
SIERRA: Is there anything that, you know,
you feel like you wanna add? Anything that
you feel like the story is missing?
SEXTON: No, I think the only thing I'll say
is that I just really appreciate all the people
that are still pushing and still trying to
make a change. And don't give up. It seems
like we're getting close.
?SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes. Have a
question or some feedback? Just feel like
saying hi? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we d love it if you
could leave us a review. Ideally a good one,
the more stars the better. It really does
help us get noticed. Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our associate podcast producer. Our intern
is Natalia Lopez. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Extra help for this episode was provided
by Kali Robinson, Sophie Yass, and Diana Roy.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke, as well as the Women in Foreign Policy
team. For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you soon!